es geht um das prinzip der
verhältnismässigkeit stadt hat regeln
aufgestellt und die sind auch nötig um
die gesundheit von menschen zu schützen
aber die schönsten regel nutzen sie
nicht wenn sich niemand dran hält
deshalb haben alle ministerpräsidenten
ich sage das ja auch und das sagt ja im
kern auch herr kubicki und herr
lindemann gesagt es geht jetzt um die
selbstverantwortung von bürgerinnen und
bürgern auch über die festtage sich an
regeln zu halten auch an beschränkungen
aber wir sind kein polizeistaat wir sind
eine demokratie und der demokratie gibt
es grundrechte und bürgerrechte die sind
jetzt zum teil was sich bitter finde aus
gründen der pandemie eingeschränkt aber
wir werden nicht wie in china
das ganze machen können wir sind keine
diktatur dass er wird nicht zu hause
kontrolliert was geht darum dass die
menschen sich vernünftig und anständig
verhalten